en qué momento de mi vida
soñé con hacer una película en qué
momento y vida soñé con conseguir un
récord guinness y por más que lo penséis
lo pensé y lo pensé no fue capaz de
encontrar regrese a casa hace un mes dos
meses tal vez y me puse a buscar cosas
viejas y me encontré un libro que yo
tenía en el colegio era un diario y allí
escribía mis sueños y me puse a leerlo
y quise ser médico y cambiaba de página
y quería ser arquitecto y cambiar de
página y quería ser el matemático y
general global como la última página que
vi quería ser diseñador gráfico pero por
más que busqué en ese libro no encontré
que mi sueño sería desafiar a los
lugares más extremos en la tierra
y me cuestiones y como puede ser posible
que todo lo que soñé no lo hice y algo
que ni siquiera lo había soñado se
convirtió en realidad en qué momento
pasó eso en qué momento entonces para
que uno sueña si al final no lo va a ser
fue fue la pregunta inmediata y pensé
que estaba solo y se empezó a contar con
mi familia me empezó a contar con mis
amigos y me di cuenta que a todos nos
había pasado lo mismo y no es que mis
amigos son unos fracasados y yo también
por ahí no va la cosa pero estaban
haciendo cosas estábamos haciendo cosas
que nunca soñamos y la pregunta era por
qué
y creo sospecho seriamente que porque
fuimos atacados por un sicario o por
varios sicarios sicarios de sueños están
en todos lados te los encuentras en
donde sea en tu familia en tus amigos
internamente los ves en donde sea te
levantas y los ves duermes y los ves los
ves en whatsapp lo ves en vídeos lo ves
en donde te dé la gana cada vez que
planteas un sueño a parecen que están
allí y claro pues te van empujando y te
van alejando de tus sueños y vas
terminando haciendo cualquier cosa la
real académia lo define
cómo
define como un asesino asalariado así lo
define ese espantoso horrible pero es lo
que pasa y yo dije wow es un tema de
sicario regresaba del desierto del
sahara en donde lo ven a pablo él estuvo
allí y era la primera noche y era para
mí la primera vez que yo veía un hombre
muriéndose al 30.000 lo encontraron
botado en medio de la nada abandonado
completamente tuvieron que ponerle 5
sueros para sacarlo de la muerte 5
sueldos para sacarlo de la muerte pero a
mí lo que más me sorprendió fue que al
lado de pablo había una botella y esa
botella estaba llena y llena de agua
llena y la capilla estaba abierta esto
no entiendes y dices cómo te puedes
morir de sed con la botella de agua
llena es que es imposible es un absurdo
y pablo me dijo loco yo resolví sea el
conservador ustedes han escuchado esa
frase yo no soy pesimista soy realista y
la gente empieza a condenarlo a sí y te
van más tantos sueños y tenemos que ver
de lo que quieres hacer pero es
imposible cuando yo les contaba de
amigos quería ir al desierto del sahara
a correr la carrera más difícil en el
mundo a correr 240 kilómetros en el
lugar más caliente del planeta en ese
momento todo el mundo te empieza a caer
encima y te dices pero verás que no es
un corredor pero verás que no corres a
tiempo completo por algo es la carrera
más difícil en el mundo quinto es creído
tú y te empiezan a marcar yo acabo esa
carrera y me fractura fue que tenía el
27% de la masa muscular desaparecía mi
cuerpo se había canibalizado la comida
que había llevado había sido
insuficiente y el desgaste era tan
fuerte que el cuerpo tuvo que sacar
energía de donde sea y se comía mis
piernas el 27 poquito de mis
isquiotibiales se acabaron me tomaron
meses en recuperarme pero lo había
conseguido y nadie me dijo nada y cuando
lancé mi siguiente aventura que era irme
al otro lado
a correr 100 km en el lugar más frío que
se pueden imaginar en donde está el 90%
del hielo del planeta en donde se ha
registrado la temperatura más baja de la
historia de la humanidad y yo siendo
monos quería correr 100 kilómetros allí
a 31 grados bajo cero una locura pues
imagínate a mí que nunca había pisado
nieve que no había vivido un invierno de
verdad y que mi concepto de frío era el
aire acondicionado quería correr 100
kilómetros a 3 grados bajo cero pues es
una locura y todo el mundo me empezó a
caer encima y me di cuenta que los
comentarios eran muy parecidos a cuando
yo quería hacer el tema del sahara los
comentarios no cambian te quieren matar
y en ese momento dije saben que voy a
hacer un experimento y me reuní con 16
personas en una cafetería en citas
diferentes ocho mujeres y ocho hombres y
les contaba que quería ir al desierto
del sahara
y un grupo me empezó a decir pero quién
eres tú ni qué te has creído y dice qué
cosas el segundo grupo se puse una
lógica colaborativa y me dijo loco yo no
he ido al sahara no he corrido eso pero
tengo una prima que trabaja en una
aerolínea a lo mejor te regalan el
pasaje te encontramos que de
fisioterapista y te puede ayudar tengo
al titular y se ponen en una lógica de
colaboración cuatro semanas después me
reunir nuevamente con las 16 personas en
citas separadas
me disculpe por haberles mentido y le
dije eso que te conté que iba a ser ya
lo había hecho
y el primer grupo más increíble que les
parezca se pusiera ninguna una posición
justificativa y empezaron a decir pero
cuando corriste en abril allá para que
en abril hace frío pues en el sahara
pero que eran seis días o en un día anda
es que yo pensé que dan un día ha
quedado en agua no yo pensé que tenía
que cargar todo el agua y mil
justificativos para que la conclusión
sea así así cualquiera pues
es lo quisimos y yo solo me queda decir
wow el man sigue convencido que lo pudo
haber hecho pero que no le dé la
regalada gana' impresionante el segundo
grupo se emociona cuando escuchas que ya
le había acabado y dijo loco que bacán
es espectacular de felicidades qué
patético porque y las preguntas fueron
ningún otro aspecto si tuvieras que
repetirlas que cosas mejorarían si
alguien quisiera hacerle te contacta
cuáles serían tus sugerencias como le
aportaría qué te parece hacer un blog y
contar todo tu proceso para que alguien
que quiera y tenga una guía y alguien
que no lo ha considerado de pronto
empieza a considerarlo en una lógica de
cómo aportar y ahí te das cuenta con esa
prueba que hay dos tipos de personas las
que soñamos y las que nos soñamos las
personas que sueñan cuando escuchan un
sueño de otra persona se emocionan y se
pone ninguna lógica colaborativa
disparan su empatía y se conectan
brutalmente las otras personas que no
son las que sueñan cuando escuchan un
sueño lo primero que piensan es
un chance sí es un sueño existe la
posibilidad de que se cumpla y si se
cumple significa que ese éxito y yo no
quiero que nadie sea exitoso la gente te
puede perdonar todo menos el éxito y esa
gente agarra toda su energía y se
convierte en el sicario y le empiezan a
dar duro porque su objetivo es matar que
el sueño te lo quieren tumbar te lo van
a tumbar ese café acaba y te escriben en
la noche un whatsapp y te dicen loco me
quedé pensando en tu idea la plena no se
puede hacer y te lo matan y se pueden
poner toda su energía y eso es
impresionante la diferencia entre el
grupo 1 y el grupo 2 es que el grupo 2
eran emprendedores y el grupo 1 eran
empleados y se creían la mamá de tarzán
y no tomaban retos tomaban actividades
pasaban ocupados se creían los super
gerentes se creían lo que te dé la gana
pero no pasaba nada espectacular en su
vida esta gente era mucho más humilde y
saben por qué el argumento es porque
para ser exitosos tienen que ser
expertos en fracasos y los fracasos son
caídas responde
y cada vez que se caigan tienen que
aprender a querer sus raspones porque lo
único que les está indicando los
raspones es que están en el camino
correcto puede ser que todos los
expertos en nada estén en contra lo que
ustedes dicen pero ustedes están en el
camino correcto porque cuando no se
compromete emocionalmente y mentalmente
con lo que quieras hacer no hay nada que
te detenga y solamente se convierte en
un tema de tiempo si lo consigues mañana
o pasado en una semana o en un mes o en
donde sea ese no es el problema el
problema es que por fin vas a
convertirte en dueño de tu propia vida
yo no soy brujo para decirles aquí que
lo que tienen ustedes en su cabeza lo
van a cumplir no es el problema mío es
de ustedes pero si les puedo afirmar que
si ustedes deciden
ser dueños de sus vidas están cambiando
todo un paradigma que lamentablemente
nos han impuesto por año y le van a
decir a todos estos sicarios que se van
a encontrar en el camino a mi a mi no me
vas a matar a mi no me vas a matar por
mas sicario de sueños me sientes como
comentario pero tú no sabes el contexto
en el que estoy yo y en el que esta mi
vida porque el dueño de mi vida soy yo
muchísimas gracias